difficulty in the moment he tries to
tango away
might be worries that is most dangerous
CG that's a walk in touchdown
[Applause]
passed up the scene
I am just competitively and athletically
but he's gonna do for the Oakland A's
hurry to the back of the endzone
touchdown
it is Carsten Meyer and he holds on took
a hit as bye dagoon with some good
sportsmanship for Kyler Murray his
fourth touchdown back he's just a guy
that has played so much ball in his life
football and baseball and basketball his
dad was a stud quarterback feel now with
to a ton of Aloha
[Applause]
- it loads it goes deeply
[Applause]
touchdown Alabama come on how do you do
this
[Music]
saturday 7-yard Jim go across the field
he's not that wide open he just delivers
the boat right on them right in strike
people don't do this kind of stuff but
only one way to get that done you got a
recruit
[Music]
steps away from it and 12t knows it's
bearing down on a sack right here he
lets it go at the last second when he
knows he's got the touchdown and Raj
gets one and he took a shot late